à la pandémie va vous imposer des
conditions de course un peu particulier
vous avez votre sac à dos et mettre
notre masque écoutez vous êtes très beau
trois de ces parties civiles chevronnés
oui oui nous combinons virus nommé russe
noviny didot je teste tous conviés tous
venters on construit on ne peut prendre
qu'une voiture où il y a que le
chauffeur sinon y'a pas l'existence
iations on peut passer ça colle porte
donc s'arrête gicam vous les chances
qu'on a trouvé un chauffard will i am
number one badiou pour l'emblème kobe ou
non on savait qu'on allait devoir faire
avec avec le co vide mais alors que ça
sera aussi dur pour comprendre non
jamais jamais j'aurais passé
[Musique]
est-ce qu'ils ont bien fait de
redémarrer le tournage
alors guillaume genton il aurait dur il
est à fond sur copenhague en reste il
adorait il aurait dû arrêter le tournage
ça a cassé toute la dynamique du
programme ce qui est intéressant dans
cette émission c'est l'immersion là ils
ont le temps de rentrer en france une
pause de six mois c'est énorme et un
truc qui m'a exaspéré hier soir ils ont
fait un teaser de cinq minutes pour
expliquer qu'ils avaient une pandémie
mondiale
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de pékin express oui bien sûr la
pandémie est là pas touché que pékin
express et merci on avait attendu pks
pop star kevin pandémie non mais c'est
vrai dit ça qui a fait ça pendant cinq
minutes je veux des non-joueurs la
[ __ ] oui stéphane riehl iv nouvelles
maps fait à temps dans tous les cas une
certitude et sienne affirmation c'est la
première fois que dans pt qu'on a connus
ces biens sont obligés de prévenir que
cela marche juste qui a dit que c'était
gênant c'est en début d'émission
si je veux dénoncer on est obligé de
prévenir que l'émission va être un peu
fou de perturber qui va demander mais
mondiale hors série devait prononcer
parce qu'on n'était pas dans la fin mais
ils sont remisés de le dire pour heroes
pour montrer qu'ils ont pris qu'ils ont
fait les gestes barrière klein démasqué
que tout est en règle et ils vont
essayer de faire comme ils peuvent pour
donner un spectacle au genre et b sont
donc les calories sont testés on n'est
pas là pour envahir un pays et pour un
dollar parce que dans tous les cas bas
tout est fait en règle sur les maps
totalement son papa non parce que nous
on adore india express oui mais bon moi
je me bats moi je vous adore lingots
pourtant je vous regarde pas
fait le plus parler hier soir c'est rose
marie et cindy après bastia c'est signe
indien
lenaria sindia elle mange pas des ailes
sont elles devraient vous plaire elles
sont belles un arrêt bowie wiwa tu call
alors pour ceux qui le regardait pas
comme moi j'en ai rien à carrer il faut
savoir ce sont deux beaux délire cette
saison ce que vous avez dit oui je sais
pas hier elles ont utilisé leurs atouts
pour convaincre un homme de les conduire
à 5 heures nous alors je vous dirai ça
me choque ou pas il paraît que sur les
réseaux lan les jours d'un soleil mais
qu'est-ce us à taulé c'est un tollé et
sir et on a dû me sucer de leurs charmes
pour faire de l'auto-stop
qu'est ce que ça veut dire m6 rembourser
voilà les gens les pauvres de vraies
pestes celle là j'espère qu'elles seront
vite éliminer les n'ont aucun amour
propre
c'est vraiment dégueulasse je déteste ce
genre de meuf qui jouent de leur
physique yamoun kick d'imama réaction
face aux parisiennes leur foutage de
gueule pour ce pauvre miri regarder bon
alors voilà ça a été un déferlement
dites-moi est-ce que vous êtes choqués
par cette séquence ou pas vous hein
moi j'ai envie de savoir là ça ça
m'intéresse ça m'intéresse oui non non
non oui car isabelle moign ah oui on va
le revoir
on rappelle que c'est sur m 6 l/100 km 6
va être vendu
ok c'est du béton contre elle un gars
s'est construit will take its kind
kalambaka baca qui est cinq heures de
route mais falloir qu'on les excite un
petit peu
rosemary et india ont une ultime pensée
pour miri qui semble comprendre qu'il ne
reverra jamais les jeunes ça on fait
quoi de mary mary midi au quai isabelle
oui eh ben oui moi leur attitude m'a
choqué alors je les aime infiniment
mais c'est vrai que quand le mec il
accepte de faire cinq heures de route
pour les conduire alors certes il
émoustillé certes si elle faisait était
moche ci l'aurait pas fait les
autoroutes
on était sauf que quand elle arrivait un
panneau ils doivent s'arrêter
immédiatement en voiture mais du coup
elles ont pas elles sont tellement dans
l'urgence qu'elles n'ont pas le même pas
basse où le mot de remerciement pour lui
si on a perdu pékin express c'était pour
ça gilles verdez si je suis franchement
quand vous n'êtes pas sur plateau c'est
chiant à mourir
oui alors c'est extrêmement choquée
parce que ces deux jeunes femmes sont
les mêmes que nous avons défendu et qui
se plaignait d'avoir été montré
quasiment nue sous la douche
et là il juste de leur charme je trouve
ça d'une hypocrisie folle et je trouve
que pour ce pauvre miri et pour tous les
grecs c'est offensant il a raison alors
oui c'est quand même un truc est tourné
de façon un petit peu de télé réalité
donc on veut savoir ce qui se passe
vraiment dans l'aventuré ce qui se passe
vraiment dans la vie et bah ça arrive
ces choses là tant pis pour lui s'il
pauvre monsieur bah il s'est fait avoir
par deux nanas c'est pas un drame
elles m'ont pas soutirer de l'argent à
ils ont eu marre mines est ravi c'est ce
qui se passe dans la vraie vie c'est pas
c'est pas il n'y a rien de mal il ya
vraiment rien de mal moi je vois pas où
est le problème
ce monsieur je pense qu'il va s'en
remettre il en a vu d'autres à mon avis
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas tout jeune
donc ça va doucement
moi je pense que vous non plus même un
petit critique vous êtes mal dans votre
club
isabelle est très bien dans son slip à
l'élever comme zemmour est dominée 2
minutes mais j'étais hyper mal et lui
quand même alors fait 5h de bagnols avec
elle et elle sur elles par de la cire et
par le corps de la femme est finalement
matthieu chalmé vous que j'aimerais
qu'on entende nicolas pernikoff mais non
mais je trouve ça hyper mal élevé ça ne
fait pas il a fait cinq heures de
bagnols elles ont fait cinq heures de
bagnolet est bien consciente de tourner
sur lui il a même offert une petite
fleur il était sympa il est fr qu'est-ce
qu'a donnée à elles s'en vont il faisait
même pas au revoir on est arrivé mais
apportent elles partent comme des vins
le je trouve ça dégueulasse non mais ça
ça nicholas vous vous auriez fait quoi
c'est une course atypique mais auront
accueilli ça y est ça y est on est
arrivé du good good things to non mais
non mais franchement je préfère limite
ce qu'elles ont fait
non je vous le dis je limite qu'ils ont
fait mais c'est incroyable c'est nicolas
pernikoff qui permet des bons points
pour savoir si on est bien élevé ou mal
élevés c'est gilles verdez qui doit dire
comment nous les femmes on doit ce
commerce eia excuse moi moi je suis 100%
d'accord avec kelly a well jouent de
leur charme
elles jouent leur séduction elles font
ce qu'elles veulent comme ça enfin en
tant que femme
heureusement sa raison et puis c'est un
jeu il ya une compétition au bout je
vois les égards mêmes raisons mais
madame edith piaf à 30 secondes
maison est long nous jouer il ya eu du
charme ça va personne n'est dupe de on
savait bien qu'elle ait fait que les
plus âgés sont chauds qui voit la belle
qui est énorme chez les plus jeunes du
plateau
oui c'est vrai il n'aurait pas je suis
âgée je suis pas choqué c'est vrai c'est
vrai j'ai trouvé extrêmement sympathique
elle tente en pleine compétition elles
sont pressés a dit de dire au revoir au
monsieur ya pas mort d'homme
elles sont mignonnes comme tout j'espère
qu'elles vont réussir
tspectacle sinon qu'est ce tu dis toi
oui en plus le monsieur il a passé un
bon moment je suppose que oui ma voiture
donc voilà qui file pour pour te
répondre rien à voir avec films et des
défis voilà là elles choisissent elles
rigolent un pub elles ont choisi c'est
ça